cool Thank You Vicki excellent well I'm
super excited to see so many people that
I know here thank you so much for coming
since we're just coming back from lunch
I wanted to start with a couple quick
questions so first of all who here has
played a game in the last month okay who
here considers themselves as any type of
creative music visual anything okay
great so this is a good amount of the
room who here other than voting has
participated in municipal or County
government or democracy in the last year
okay pretty good pretty good for the
crowd who who did before the age of 25
Wes what's up good so we have a unique
sample in this room but generally that's
generally that's participating in
democracy particularly local democracy
is something that a lot of people don't
come around to doing until later in life
and so when I would be talking about is
how we can use games to engage more
especially young people with local local
government and local democracy and so I
come at this from a a background in
education and nonprofits I study media
production and games and learning and
undergrad at the University of Wisconsin
I then spent about 10 years working in
all different kinds of capacities doing
curriculum development game and story
based learning especially in the maker
education space and for me after the
2016 election I really found myself
questioning whether I was in the right
space I went back to Wisconsin which is
where I'm from and I had been doing a
whole bunch of interviews with people
there people on the right and the left
I'm trying to understand what was
happening with this severe polarization
in our in our
even among my family and that really
looking into that problem really brought
me to a new awareness of this so we have
a crisis of civic literacy and
engagement in this country in 2016 the
United States was the first time for the
first time downgraded from a full
democracy to a flawed democracy and I
think that a big part of this has to do
with our civic education system in the
United States in an assessment of
standards in 32 States and Washington DC
it was found that no States have
experienced real learning or local
problem-solving components and their
civics requirements and again that's all
of the states they looked at including
Wisconsin so that experiential learning
with civics may happen but it's not
required so it's really you know this is
just the beginning of the problem
because a 2016 Annenberg study found
that only 26% of Americans can name all
three branches of government we have a
really big problem and this is at the at
the federal government level that
doesn't even touch on what happens in
local and county government who your
city representatives are what a
municipal resolution is what a County
referendum is none of that stuff is
taught in school in most states so again
I'm from Wisconsin Wisconsin I will be
bringing up multiple times because this
is where I conducted most of my research
I spent a lot of the last year looking
at civic engagement practices in central
Wisconsin particularly in smaller cities
and the organization I worked most
closely with is called Wisconsin United
to amend their a small social movement
organization they're based in Madison
but they work all over the state and
they are working on the issue of money
and politics and what their goal is is
to get a 28th amendment to the
Constitution that addresses addresses
this issue and in Wisconsin campaign
finance and the role of money in
politics became a particularly big issue
in 2012 so I understand if you don't all
follow Wisconsin politics so I'll give
you
a quick little recap here in 2012
protesters were able to demand a recall
election of our of our then Governor
Scott Walker if you may remember this
was this is in the news quite a bit
there are tons of protests tons of
people taking action on this that recall
election did not succeed and part of the
reason for that is that Scott Walker and
his campaign was able to raise thirty
million dollars from primarily
out-of-state donors including up to 19
million dollars that came from Koch
backed organizations whereas his
opponent only raised four million
dollars primarily from in-state donors
there's a huge issue in terms of the
role that money plays in our government
locally in Wisconsin and throughout the
country and of course there's all kinds
of other issues that we face the you
know Wisconsin GoDaddy and their state
integrity report in 2015 there's a lot
that people could be organizing around
but in a lot of places it's not
happening but in Madison there's some
interesting things that are happening
and that is that even in the midst of
this really frustrating political moment
of this 2012 recall election we had
things like this this is the Imperial
Walker referencing Star Wars this was a
costume that showed up around the recall
elections in 2012 they actually would
rock walk around yelling the Imperial
Walker never stops and it was really it
was really popular among protesters it
was something that other people started
to copy
you know memes were created stickers
were printed it became part of the
movement and it was fun it was something
that was fun
and that's what I want to talk about and
focus on quite a bit in in this talk is
how we can connect people to the fun of
movements and how games might be able to
help us do that as a way to onboard
people into taking more civic action
so my focus was protected for
specifically on grassroots organizing at
the municipal in the county level and
what I argue is that we need to be
looking more closely at this field of
participatory engagement which is sort
of the overlap of participatory culture
on which many people are probably
familiar with in terms of Henry Jenkins
work and civic engagement and what I'm
gonna argue is that games can be a key
part of how we bring these things
together so for the rest this talk I'm
gonna go over a few things here first
I'll talk about my research the second
two sections are some of my findings and
then finally I'm going to talk about the
game that I've been developing over the
last year as part of my thesis work to
address this problem in Appleton
Wisconsin so first of all research my
main research question which I was
surprised in looking over all of my
different presentations of these thesis
ideas to see you like that this actually
kind of followed through a little bit it
is how might nonprofits and social
movement organizations leverage the
principles of game based learning and
game design thinking to increase civic
engagement and civic literacy and so
there's kind of four different sub parts
of this that I was thinking about one of
it is I was really looking specifically
at location-based games and thinking
about how the affordances of that type
of game can support local action I was
thinking about how the idea of
participatory futurism or the ways that
different people can come together to
think about the future in a more
positive light
could play a role I was doing a lot of
work looking at the existing tools that
support both social movement
organizations and activists and then
like I said I really wanted to focus on
places outside of the large urban
centers I think there's a lot of work
especially in the Civic innovation and
technology space or in places like
Chicago and Boston and I was curious
about what was happening in you know a
70 thousand person City in the middle of
Wisconsin all the way down to a two
thousand person City
so first these are some of the things
that I pulled from for my my literature
review I looked a lot at social movement
studies particularly looking at creative
activism and youth activism also looked
at the field of civic media and
location-based media and then finally I
pulled a lot from the games in learning
field and again this is more of my my
background what I was familiar with
coming in and it was really useful to
kind of frame some of the other things
that I was learning in terms of primary
research first I did a lot of
ethnographic research at 15 interviews
tons and tons of calls for community
design sessions and a survey in
Wisconsin and then I also did a bunch of
design based research which included for
Public Library installations and intead
integrations of the game that I've been
working on so these are just some of the
pictures of all of that this was the
biggest installation that was in
Appleton last summer some of you
recognize this and I forced you to play
test it last year mm-hmm so I'll go into
a little bit more of that
so findings the first big piece that I
was starting to notice was that there's
this difference between participatory
and institutional forms of engagement
and what I really pulled from and when I
started thinking about this was 2012
piece from Bennett and segeberg I called
the logic and connective action and they
argue that connective action functions
differently than more traditional
collective action well the logic of
collective action emphasizes uniform
framing in the function of SMOS as a
dominant organizing bodies the logic of
connective action suggests that digital
media are also strong organizing
structures sorry I suppose means social
movement organizations so they say when
people who seek more personalized paths
to concerted action are familiar with
the practices of social networking and
everyday life and when they have access
to technologies from mobile phones to
computers they're already familiar with
a different logic of organization the
logic of connective action
and this is also reflected in the use of
the research that's been done by the
youth participatory politics Research
Network on how youth engage with with
politics and Kathy Cohen has really been
a leader in this work
in her research she talks about these
two different types of political
engagement institutional and
participatory and this really reflects
these overall changes we're seeing in
the world in terms of how our phones and
our connectivity changed pretty much
everything this is how it works for
particularly youth in the Civic space so
I'm gonna really really simplify overly
simplify this to take you through what
these mean first institutional
engagement I have my bring on the
fundraising emails here institutional
engagement is kind of your traditional
approach to digital organizing that a
lot of social movement organizations
pursue it's really driven by the idea of
the marketing funnel it's top-down
there's only a few calls to action it
doesn't do a good job supporting local
action they're just like let's push all
this stuff out and then hopefully we'll
get a few people to make a donation and
actually looks was looking at my emails
from all the organizations that I follow
in Wisconsin and in the month in
November over let's say I think over 55%
of them the only call to action was to
donate no I wanted to just have like a
response to be like I'm a grad student
no on the other hand we've got
participatory engagement and this is
very different typically more popular
among younger people and this is much
less like a funnel and more like a
ladder that uses popular culture to
onboard people into movements and one of
the organizations that Henry Jenkins
writes a lot about it in this space is
called the Harry Potter Alliance which
basically uses the fictional world of
Harry Potter to get people engaged in
politics all over the world and there's
a few different features of this
participatory engagement that I kind of
identified in looking at a lot of the
work on this space first these forms of
engagement tend to be remixable they
tend to be very diverse so it could be a
really
locate a difficult thing it could be a
really easy thing and there's a lot of
different ways to engage they tend to be
modular which means like that Imperial
Walker costume I can look at a picture
of that and I can find a way to
replicate that and potentially repurpose
it for different causes and they're also
personalizable so I can kind of put my
stamp and use it as a way to express
something about Who I am and so I think
overall and organizing we really need
both of these approaches we need both
those like these funnels and these
ladders because we live in a diverse
world and we need diverse ways to engage
but what I've seen is that right now in
the technology space there are very very
few tools that support more
participatory forms of engagement so I
did an analysis of over 20 different
tools that are used both by existing
social movement organizations and by
activists and I generally just found
that a lot of these technologies are
very one-way they again focus on a
limited set of calls to action they're
just generally not aligned with this
more participatory form of engagement
and so overall in looking at the tools
that exist in this space I kind of
noticed these three trends one is that
very very few of them if any of them
really support local action at the
municipal in the county level the second
is there's not a ton of collaboration
that is supported in these tools usually
an organization will maybe put together
an app to support their cause
but then they don't end up getting a lot
of users and it's not maintained very
well and all of these other issues
happen and and it just kind of ends up
getting ignored and beat by being
collaborative I think that you can I'll
talk about this more but you can get
more people involved and you can do a
better job supporting the technology and
then finally just what I've been talking
about they're not particularly
participatory so the next section I'm
going to look at game design and how we
can use it as a tool to drive more of
this type of participatory engagement
so the first thing here is I talked in
the in the thesis a lot about the idea
of game design thinking and this is my
definition of game design thinking and
approach to the design of civic
technology that uses the structure of a
game to model complex social problems in
a way that makes them easier for
community members to understand and
engage with this is different from other
definitions both Ben Stokes and your
Gordon used this idea in slightly
different ways and then I think are also
very useful but this is kind of how I
how I was using it how do we use games
to think about the complex structure of
the social movement field and make it
easier to understand how you can plug in
so this is really essentially the second
chapter of my thesis and it's organized
around the resident games framework
which is in Resident games which is from
the education arcade here and they
identify these kind of four principles
of of learning learning games and they
are under the whole learner under the
sociology of learning a play the deep
connection between content and game and
the learning context so I'm just gonna
very briefly go through each of these
sections in this chapter a couple of the
takeaways that I found certainly not an
exam
so first of all I rephrase this one is
playing and learning how do we look at
the connection between the content in
the game and in resident games they say
if you're asking how do I make this
topic fun you're asking the wrong
question what you really want to do is
try to find what's already fun about a
particular process and then connect
players to that so what I was thinking
about social movements again this pulls
me back to this idea of creative
activism what is already fun about
taking part in a grassroots movement and
then the other thing in this part that I
wanted to highlight is the idea of
scaffolding so you know in learning
theory we talked about the zone of
proximal development which is basically
how do we keep people kind of just at
the edge of their comfort zone so that
they can can be continually learning
through an experience experience and
what I see in a
lot of the particularly digital forms of
websites for participating with large
social movement organizations is that
they don't really scaffold engagement
very well a lot of the time that's one
example you might go on you might say
I'm interested and they'll ask you to
tweet something is the first step like
okay I can I can do that and then after
that it says you know next step and the
next step is start a local chapter which
is like this massive as great if I go
find other people there's nothing in
between and I think that this idea of
scaffolding even if it was just this
whole loan could be really helpful in
designing civic technologies that can
support that type of engagement second I
talk about identity and expression this
kind of speaks to the idea that learners
are not you know an empty vessel we
already have things that we know and we
need to be able to build off and connect
to those things and there's there's four
pieces here the first is we need to make
personal expression a mechanism of
achieving the desired engagement goal
again for in my case I think this
relates to creative activism second
contribution creates ownership and
belonging so Sasha talks a lot about
this in their book on transmedia
organizing and talking about how
creating a you know a video or telling
your story through some form of media
really increases your sense of
connection to a particular movement
third I think participatory culture very
well fits in with this how do we
personalize what we're sharing and what
we're doing and then finally we needed
to support spread ability so you can't
just build for one platform it's got to
be able to things have got to be able to
be shared
next collaboration and community this is
another thing that I think we could
really learn from when we look at Civic
technologies in general but specifically
for the organising space and there's
again four things here the first is we
need to support reputation and
reciprocity so the ability for people to
engage and build relationships over time
to be affirmative with low barriers to
entry its prints pretty self-explanatory
promote
peer learning and training and promote
collaboration so the the two key points
here are with collaboration again this
kind of speaks to that logic of
connective action how do we create tools
that can support a large number of
issues and causes and enable people to
connect and say hey like you know I
follow three fifty.org because I care
about climate change but I didn't know
about like the Sun rise movement and all
of these other things that I might also
be doing and in terms of peer learning
when I was an undergrad I studied with
Constance 10 cooler who does a lot of
work on World of Warcraft and how people
in the game of World of Warcraft learn
from and teach each other and there's a
really there's really interesting
customs that exist in that game and in
many other games that can show us how
players more advanced players can be
mentors for new players and I think that
there's also something to that that
could be really useful for an experience
for onboarding people into the space of
organizing and then finally strategy and
context again lore on or the learning
context so first this really for me is
what got me is just start thinking about
location-based games is a useful medium
for for the problem I was looking at
because they promote habits of
connection to place and what I mean by
that is really demonstrated while in
research on the game called Mogi which
was the precursor to pokemon go and what
the researchers found in looking at
players of that game is that the players
will actually like throughout the course
of their day change where they go in
order to interact with different sites
in the game and when I started playing
Pokemon go I noticed that I was doing
the same thing you're like oh that's
statue outside the lab like I got to
stop by there I'm not going to go this
way because I want to play over here and
I think there's something about that
like visual cue of a space that you see
that could be really useful for a civic
engagement game especially if it's
focused on local issues which also
relates to the idea of situating
learning and engagement so if there's
something I want you to know about the
library can I put that information at
the library
and then finally in this section I also
thought a lot about knowledge games and
specifically crowdsourcing so one of the
big challenges of you know information
systems at the local level is there's
tons and tons and tons of local elected
representatives so are there ways that
we can build it into the game to
actually collect information about who
holds those positions and what their
stances are on different issues what
information do we need to know at the
local level and can we incentivize play
around learning that so thinking about
all of that I'm gonna just spend a
couple minutes here taking you through
the game itself which is called forward
again this was built for the city of
Appleton Wisconsin that's a seventy five
thousand person City so that's just a
little bit south of Green Bay
it's tends to be pretty conservative
although there's an interesting mix of
organizations there and first I just
want to touch a little bit on on
Wisconsin context so I think that when
we think of Wisconsin there are certain
things that come to mind which are all
very well represented on our state
quarter we have a cow and we have cheese
and corn but one thing that a lot of
people don't know is that our state
motto is forward and Wisconsin has a
really strong tradition of organizing of
activism and of progressive ideas and
this isn't typically reflected in a lot
of our politics in the state's today but
it's something that I'd like to be able
to remind people of and so that's kind
of why I chose this name forward is
thinking and also because I want people
to actually think forward think about
the future as a way to kind of get past
our more partisan barriers so forward is
a location-based civic engagement game
that can extractivist with Action Alerts
called missions based on their interests
skills availability and location
throughout the game players collect
elements to complete missions with other
players in support of local causes and
completing these missions allows players
to submit and vote on headlines
about the state's future so this is
gonna be launching a pilot of this three
five weeks on a web app starting on July
4th so wish me luck in building that
over the next month and the hypothesis
is that games can facilitate structured
cross move and collaboration between
organizations and their supporters
thereby increasing both issue awareness
and personalization of calls to action
at the local level and so first I wanted
to define what are some of my goals and
creating this experience the number one
goal is to promote creative activism I
want to expand how people think about
civic engagement so if I can get
somebody to do one piece of chalk art or
make one meme and tag it in a location
in the city like I consider that a win
other things of course are just about
learning about local government and
local civics and then again thinking
positively about the future shifting the
frame of how we're thinking about these
issues so the game's story is that we
are trying to collaboratively write a
futuristic edition of the local paper
for May 29 2014 1 since 200th birthday
and the way this works is that as you
play the game negative headlines which
are sourced crowd-sourced from the
community show up and then you have to
counteract them as a player by putting
in positive headlines and you've got to
get enough likes on your positive
headlines that they beat out the
negative ones
so the first step when you join this
game is you actually create a little
avatar this is part of that identity
formation expression piece something
that we actually found was really really
popular in paper prototyping this is a
little Avatar card that one of the early
players filled out and we randomly
picked this like aesthetic of these cute
little animals with like superhero stuff
like superhero costumes and I just kind
of like continued going with that
because people seem to like it
and so this is kind of the over the mock
up sort of promo thing of the game
you're trying to run around and collect
these different elements and it's all
it's all place-based
so the different components of the game
itself first we have tactics tactics are
templates for creative civic engagement
so if anybody's familiar with
Instructables I really like the way that
they do this
um step by step how did you create your
Imperial Walker
you know what materials did you need and
I want to start with about 50 different
tactics in the game and then
participants can also add their own and
those tactics exist in three different
categories which are guided by our three
little non player characters here we've
got the honey badger for advocacy the
dragon pug for a creative and nerdy corn
for research so these represent
different types of tactics that you can
engage with and you can level up in each
of these categories as you go through
the game next campaigns so this is kind
of what you think of what our local
organizations trying to achieve I'm
gonna be sourcing these campaigns from a
minimum of 15 different organizations
and I just want to know you know are you
trying to get a you know get a certain
number of signatures on a petition pass
a local resolution what tangibly are you
trying to succeed or achieve and how can
our players through creative activism
support that so missions are how they do
that missions combine a tactic and a
campaign and enable people to run out
into the community and do something to
raise awareness about that thing it
could be something that you see somebody
doing like actually dressing up or doing
a flash mob or it could be just them
digitally tagging and geo-locating a
digital piece of media for other players
to find which they'll be part of the
test to see what works with that story
is just document the completion of
missions those are the things that you
like in order to get points for the
headlines which of course is how you
influence the overall story and again I
want this to be something that can serve
multiple organizations these are the
five different issues that the game
looks at and so we'll be working with
hopefully I'm in a moment of three
organizations on each of these issues to
define
the sort of pre initial set of missions
and you can also do team play I won't
get into how that works but teams if
I've done people are supported to
hopefully see if that's something that
other people enjoy doing and so with
that I just want to say thank you first
of all to Scott and Sasha my thesis
advisors too you know Wisconsin United
to amend all the people that I worked
with in Wisconsin the city of Appleton
the Appleton Public Library and of
course all of the CMS faculty and my
cohort who's been really really amazing
I think I learned somehow I learned more
here than I could have possibly imagined
and I'm just extremely grateful to have
spent the last two years with you all
thank you
[Applause]
so
yeah so I think the question is
generally about who is this for
and the short answer is help to learn
that this summer was I piloted the the
key audiences that I'm targeting are
people who are already following an
organization but maybe aren't very
involved for example Wisconsin United to
amend has 8,000 people on their mailing
list but they have about 20 people who
come to meetings regularly so good we
get maybe this is a way that some of
those people would want to engage as
opposed to the other ways they've been
offering the second is youth creatives
so people who maybe are already creating
different forms of political art let's
just haven't been connected to any
specific issues I did a digital
engagement survey that also asked a lot
of questions about what teenagers were
what organizations teenagers were aware
of and it just generally seems that in
in this in the community is that I've
been looking at there's just a really
big disconnect there so it you know can
we just connect the kids who are already
being creative to using that in a way
that supports an organization and then
finally the last group is just kids who
are who are already civically engaged
which is pretty pretty small group and
this summer this will be supported
through partnering with the with
Appleton downtown which is like our
local they run the farmers market and
the summer concert series and do a lot
of public events so hopefully they'll be
able to help us get more of the public
involved and then also working with the
local Boys and Girls Club teen centers
so they'll actually be building play
into their days so I know that I'll at
least have some participants who will go
through the whole experience does that
answer it
yeah okay so the question is can't could
this be co-opted for nefarious purposes
and it is it already cut yeah so I've to
it two pieces I want to touch on first
isn't necessarily I don't wanna say the
bad guy but I did note I did see an
article pretty recently about I think
it's like the Vatican released a Pokemon
go version of like like following Jesus
or finding Jesus or something along
those lines so like the idea of using
location-based games for these different
like spaces is certainly like possible
in my game what I've tried to do is gone
back and forth on this a lot but
ultimately again I want to focus on the
future as a way to step aside from these
partisan barriers and I think I'm going
to try to do it in a non-partisan way
although my hope is that those five
issue areas will generally
only really apply to organizations that
are trying to move in a more positive
direction for everyone and especially
given I think the state of the
Republican Party right now with so many
people feeling politically homeless and
that was something that I saw a lot and
my research last summer I don't want to
say it's a progressive thing because I
think it's something that people from
across the political spectrum might be
able to get behind so yeah the the goal
is to be non partisan generally
organizing around the idea of creating a
better community in the future Lisa
Oh
yeah that's a great question and
something I didn't touch on so like I
said I want to start with about 50
different sort of tutorials on different
things you can do that you know would
include yeah baby if you like to knit
this is something and then there will be
an onboarding process you'll be able to
say like I like doing these things and
then it'll give you some initial
suggestions but you can also add those
as you level up and not only can you add
tactics you can also add campaigns and
admissions and adding missions I think
could be a core piece of game back play
that ties into the team component
because the way it works is you you
create the mission and then you actually
get points for not only you doing it but
anybody else who does that mission so
it's trying to get people to come up
with more creative ways to engage and
part of what I think could be
interesting out of this is just creating
a big database of all of those
possibilities so yeah I definitely want
it to be something that can expand
all right thank you
[Applause]